I was destroyed like on the ground like
crying like it's because that that's a
loss that's a it's a death honestly you
grieve something that you thought would
be forever Kelly Clarkson not holding
back about her experience with divorce
you know it's just divorce is a really
thing the star appeared on Angie
Martinez's IRL podcast on Monday and
doesn't sugarcoat when it comes to
discussing her split with ex-husband
Brandon Blackstock I think the thing
about divorce that you know especially
having it publicized like it's just you
know and people thinking they know the
whole yeah thing the hardest part of
that is like it wasn't an overnight
decision I'm not the person to be like
oh what you know oh it never had or
nothing like that no it was beautiful
for a minute you know I'm saying it was
awesome for a minute and then and that's
okay it just didn't work out not only
does Kelly lay it all out on the table
but she reveals her open and honest
relationship with their kids
eight-year-old River and six-year-old
Remy a lot of times it would be like you
know I'm just really sad you know I wish
Mommy and Daddy were in the same house I
wish and they're really honest about it
and that's and I'm raising that kind of
individual I want you to be honest with
me and I just sit there and I'm like I
get it I'm from a divorced family as
well I get it that's that sucks you know
but we're gonna work it out and you are
so loved by both of us I am an open book
but at some point I'm a mama bear more
than I am a person in the public eye so
I care 100 more about my children than I
do anything else on this planet
another way Kelly's getting real about
her heartbreak channeling it into some
new music a lot of it obviously is about
the last two years and and it's
basically this Arc if I didn't have the
outlet I didn't know if I was going to
release an album because I was like
I don't know if I want to talk about
this you know what I'm saying like you
you ride it all out and you get it all
out and it's all there it's like I
needed that I wrote so much like
whatever your art form is or however you
express yourself whatever your outlet is
like that's what that was for get it out
getting it out like I don't know how
anybody I'll just be real with you goes
through
grief like divorce any kind of grief any
kind of loss without having an outlet
like it has I have written like 60 songs
like it's like an insane amount of
getting it out and the singer admits
another marriage might not be in the
cards
I fell in love so deeply I experienced
that I feel so much gratitude for that
but I really do like truly
love being single like I yes I do maybe
one day I'm not like singing I'm against
it I won't be getting married I would
love to fall in love like I would love
to find someone and fall in love and do
that thing but I I have children and
that's why I say it's not that I'm like
against marriage I'm saying I have
children I have the most positive
experience with
step situations and like remarrying I
will not do that to my children I'm just
careful also while being real
[Music]
foreign